okay so there's been a lot of
talk that we had on two-party secure
computation i won't
define it
we all know what the house garvel
circuits are i will not define that what
we're going to be interested in is we're
going to be interested in
considering ram analogs of karbal
circuits so we want
what yao gave for garbol circuits we
wanted for ram programs
so let me define the problem a little
more precisely we have a user and he has
some program p and an input x so think
of this program as a ram program just
like yao had as a as a circuit
and this prog this user wants to send
this program and the input in some
garbled form so you want to send garbled
program and the garbled input x denoted
here in red so this is this is in the
clear this is garble
such that the server can learn p of x
the output of the program on this input
in the clear okay so yao gave a solution
for for the setting of circuits uh but
for ramp programs if you started with a
program p
ah say of running time t and and you
wanted to use your solution then you the
size of this garbling uh which will
which will result first by taking this
program first converting it to a circuit
and then generating a garbling
would grow with size uh a cubic in the
running time of the original program up
to log factors ignoring log factors uh
which is which is a substantial hit in
in performance but we are interested in
an even a more ambitious goal which is
of
so in particular uh here the
communication complexity which is the
size of the garble program and the
communica
the computational complexity of both the
user who generates this garble
program and the server who computes on
it grows with tq but as i said we are
interested in this more ambitious goal
of sub-linear uh
effort in in communication so in
particular we have a user who has this
huge database
what all talked about is big data
and and this user wants to send this
huge database to the server
in an encrypted form so that server does
not learn what the contents of this
database are
and at this point user has a sequence of
programs so let's say first program pi
with an input x i then he would like to
run on this
encrypted database that now rests with
the server
so when he runs this uh in this this
program on this uh with this database on
this input
you should learn the output pixel
depending on what this database is
and as this computation is is performed
uh
so the color of
okay so as this computation is performed
this database changes and as this
database changes and programs more and
more programs are executed we want those
programs to be up executed on the
updated database okay
so if you were to use garble circuits in
this setting then uh the size of uh the
amount of work that the user has to do
per program
uh also the communication complexity as
well as the amount of work the server
has to do needs to grow with the size of
the database so in particular the
circuit must take in as input the entire
database in one shot okay so for every
program you have to communicate that
uh what we would instead like to do is
that the the first
message in which this user stores this
encrypted database we want the size of
this garbled database to grow only
linearly in the size of the database
and then secondly we want the
communication and the computational cost
for each specific program to grow only
linearly in the the running time of that
specific program okay so here uh the
tilde hides polynomial factors in the
security parameter and the poly
logarithmic factors in the size of the
database the running time and so on okay
so this is the problem is the problem
clear
sorry
yes the the second thing the
communication competition goes with the
running time yeah so the user also knows
the database no the user once uh shipped
the database now it remembers nothing
about the database what if the running
time depends on the contents of the
database
like what if the first video so for now
think of the setting where the
you know any priority bound and we're
going to have that if you want to have
input specific running times you can you
can have solutions for that but we're
not going to talk about that in this
talk okay
any other questions
okay so this is uh what our user wants
so this is a
if you were to think about an example
let's say this database is uh you know
the record of
all the terrorists that exist or all the
cryptographers that exist in the world
and you wanted to do binary search on
them then the amount of work that is
done per program is is logarithmic in
the the size of the the terrorist that
probably is larger than the number of
cryptographers in the world
um
so you you don't want this communication
cost to grow with the number of
cryptographers in the world just
logarithmic in the uh the number of
cryptography okay so there are two kinds
of security notions that i can define
the first is the full security notion
which is sort of what we are interested
in which says that the server should
learn nothing at all about
the database or what's happening except
the output okay the second notion is the
unprotected memory access where the
server so this program
runs in time that is much smaller than
the size of the database so you cannot
read the entire database it can only
read parts of this database so in in
making these choices it reveals to the
server what parts it's reading and we're
okay to leak what parts it's reading
okay so this might er er
this reveals some information
for the rest of the talk i'll focus on
this notion the reason is that if you
took this notion and plugged in
oblivious ram by goldrich and ostrovsky
then you get a full security solution so
that sort of follows in a relatively
black box way uh we'll need some
additional ram properties in special
settings but we will mainly focus on the
unprotected memory case okay is that
clear okay so what is the landscape of
results and the the setting of garble
ram so the first construction was was
proposed by lewinstrovsky in europe 13
and and the result sort of relies on a
on on a somewhat complicated assumption
in in short you cannot reduce the
security of the construction to a simple
computational assumption so sort of as a
flavor of circular secure complicated
assumption it was improved by
gentry at all where they got a
construction based on ibe
and uh
for garble ram and a second result which
was based on one-way function
but
but but did not get the kind of
efficiency guarantees that i uh promised
her
this talk we have an upcoming paper with
lewis roski and
where we get the result uh that's just
based on one functions but what's very
crucial in all these results uh is is
that they make a a non-black box use of
the one-way functions in particular
you cannot model the one-way function
that's being used as a random article in
implementing these constructions so they
take the the code of the one-way
function which is then again garbled
inside the construction okay so yes
they already did one way no
so it had two results one was based on
ibe that got exactly the kind of
efficiency that i said and then there
was another uh result based on one way
function but it did not get the kind of
secure the kind of efficiency that i
aimed for it had an additional loss and
uh so when you were sending the garble
program the size grew additionally with
n to the epsilon when was the size of
the memory for some constant epsilon
right
so i'm not going to be focusing on these
results the focus of this talk is going
to be how can we
move forward and base constructions just
making only black box use of one-way
functions and this is a qualitative uh
efficiency improvement in particular uh
in this construction it's it's also
based on just on one way functions uh
the the improvement is in the sense that
the
in this result the communication cost
for example of the protocol does not
depend on the computational
efficiency of the one-way function that
you're using as an example okay
as a side remark i want to i will not
talk about the succinct garble ram
construction that are based on io so
those results are very interesting uh
but they're not the focus of this talk
uh and we're going to get the security
here based on a much weaker assumption
namely one-way functions okay
so
i mean
so someone has to do the work so
computation is happening right so the in
the setting of succinct the server does
the work
the the user's work is going to become
independent of the running time of the
program as well as the communication
cost okay so in particular
only the server does the real work
everybody else just watch watches what
the server does
you have a much weaker assumption but
the client does the work yes yes so both
the client and the server do work
proportional to the running time as well
as the communication cost but the the
dependence is only in the uh on one way
functions okay
okay so outline for the rest of the talk
i'll start by
describing what the ram model is then
the core thing that i want to convey in
this talk is what is the technical
bottleneck that comes up in realizing a
black box construction
and and to explain that i'll give you
the lua ostrovsky construction as a the
kind of ideas they had
and from there on i'll give the high
level idea of the black box construction
that we have okay so let me start with
the ram model so we have this external
memory the cpu takes various steps so
cpu has a state that it takes as input
it reads a bit from memory
outputs the next index that it's
interested in reading pass it on the
state to the next cpu step reads the the
this next bit that was intended and so
on and this process continues okay so
this is the ram model
i'm going to ignore the rights here so
sometimes a lot more and sometimes much
less work needs to be done to handle the
rights but for sort of the the whole
talk we'll now worry about rights and
we'll just look at the ram programs that
do just read okay
so the first step in the lewis roski
approach was to take this
if you have the running time you take
this each cpu step and give a separate
garble circuit for that step okay so
that i can just do by garbling each cpu
step
i also need to somehow encrypt this
memory and then enable these reads so as
i said we're only going to focus on uma
security so i'm not trying to hide the
the read patterns but as i mentioned we
can get rid of this limitation by using
oram
so what i'm going to do is how do we do
these reads uh
i'm going to do it in sort of a explain
it in two-step process
uh the lewis roski approach the first is
in garbling this memory and the second
is to generate translate table so let me
explain how
we got how lewistrovsky garbled this
memory and then explain how reads happen
so
the approach for garbling is
sample a prf key k
and if
location i of the memory contains a bit
bi then the server is provided with a
prf evaluation on i comma b i under key
k okay so this is just an encryption of
this bit in some fancy form okay
is that clear
so very simple what's happening here
next
we want to generate a translate table
that will equip reading at this step so
these are garble circuit this circuit
needs a label for it to know what the
red value is and how is that going to
happen so in particular this garble
circuit can output a value j in the
clear that it needs to be read
and this garbled circuit has two input
labels c two and s one and it needs one
of them to proceed in particular
it needs
s b j s subscript b subscript j right
how how they how how are they able to
enable it they embedded a secret the brf
key in each of the cpu steps
and
the first step for example could output
an encryption of prf k j 0
encryption of s 0 under this key and
encryption of s 1 under this key
now if the memory look at the the jth
memory location it contains the prf key
corresponding to one of them so you will
be able to decrypt only one of them
enabling you to
obtain sbj
obtain sbj and move the computation
forward okay so it's sort of very clear
that
this cpu step is inherently non-black
box because it's computing a prf inside
itself as well as doing an encryption of
s0 under that okay
so this actually you know uh uh it seems
like a really so the other constructions
which are follow up even the final one
which is based on one function sort of
inherently have this property that there
is some prf evaluation happening inside
the circuit
so so this is the the key technical
bottleneck that existed in the previous
constructions in particular if you were
to think if there is a server i have to
keep my data with it it has to be
encrypted in some way right it has to be
encrypted in some way otherwise it can
read all that value
now if it's encrypted and i have a
garble circuit that needs to read these
encrypted values i must read the
ciphertext and decrypt them inside
myself to be able to use them so it
seems like
we might not be able to to go beyond
this barrier
but a sort of acute idea work works and
we're able to avoid this uh
so the the high level idea is that
instead of having the
garbled memory as a ciphertext we're now
going to have the garble memory as sort
of a collection of guardable circuits
with the data values hardwired in them
so this is sort of a high level idea in
the next slide i'll show a picture will
become clear but sort of this high level
ideas
is good to build intuition
and the read is implemented
by passing the control flow of the main
program itself to the garbled circuit
probe so at some point in the when i
want to read a bit i start the memory
garble circuits the memory cardboard
circuits are huge it's a huge collection
depends on the size of the database some
of those garble circuits are going to be
executed and the main garble circuit is
going to be restarted with the red value
so it's a kind of access access yes
exactly it's like a subroutine call that
you make something happens and then you
get the information back
so let me describe that we have two cpu
steps just like before this cpu step
outputs the the bit the location j that
i am interested in reading
and what i want to enable is
output sbj
okay and my memory is going to look like
falling or the garbled memory is going
to look like a tree
i have a root garble circuit it has two
children and so on
the number of
leaves in the industry is going to
correspond to the size of the database
itself and in each leaf i'm going to
hard code one bit of the database
so in the root i'm going to hard code
the input labels of both its children
and so on
when i want to read the location j what
this
what the circuit does it's going to have
hard code in it
so right now i'm describing the solution
for the setting where i'm only trying to
enable one read i'm looking at a program
where i'm just i'm happy if i'm able to
succeed in doing one read in a black box
way we'll then see how we can extend it
to do more reads but this sort of
conveys the idea in a very nice way
so i have this location j i'll try start
this root garble circuit with inputs
this location j that i'm interested in
reading
as well as s0 and s1 the two input
labels for the next carbon circuit
okay
now this variable circuit has hard coded
net the input labels of its two children
let's say j was two so i'm interested in
reading the the bit b2 this guy can
decide
that it needs to go left to be able to
read this bit so it uh
this carbon circuit gets executed and
then the left child will be executed and
finally i'll be able to to read this
garbled circuit which has the bit b2
hard code in it
with all this information on js0 s1
being passed along down
at this point this garble circuit knows
what b2 is and can output sp2
which then can be fed into the next step
enabling the next cpu step
okay is this clear how one read is done
so the the key problem with the solution
is after you do one read this memory is
no longer useful this guy
is no longer exists what is the next guy
supposed to do when he invokes it
what is the relationship between the
nodes
so the input labels of these two garble
circuits are hardcoded in this
and and for so each
node contains the input hard code in it
the input labels of its children
yeah i mean it can be in the clear as
well it's a garbled circuit right
any other questions
so it it emulates in a garbage way yes
exactly how raw programs yes
architecture accessing index yes yes yes
the the the idea for uh enabling
multiple reads is to now uh so there are
a lot of technicalities here i'll just
give you the high level idea the high
level idea is though instead of having
just one garbled circuit i'm going to
have a sequence of garble circuits okay
so the root is going to have a sequence
of garble circuits once the first
garbled circuit gets consumed hopefully
the second one is going to replace it in
some way we'll see
how the question is how many
backups do we need and how do we connect
them yes
it is going to be so right now i'm only
dealing with the case where i'm allowing
for m reads where m is the size of the
memory
in future so i did the things for the
case where i was doing one read now i'm
doing for the setting where i'm doing m
reads uh and no more than that where m
is the size of the memory then i'll
extend it to the setting where i will be
able to handle arbitrary number of reads
uh without
increasing the size of the memory beyond
being linear in m
that's good
great question thanks
uh so how many backups
the if if i was to take uh just a this
program could access
arbitrary locations in in memory and it
could want to read the first location
every time and so i might have to
give a large number of uh
backups for the leftmost child for
example
uh what we're going to do is going to
simplify this problem we're going to
assume
that the memory access patterns are
uniform okay so this
is this is not true about an arbitrary
program but once you compile it with an
orm it's still not completely true but
in a start version of it is true which
suffices for construction and i will
sort of focus only in the case where you
have uniform memory accesses okay
if you have uniform memory accesses then
we're sort of at least ready to answer
the first question how many backups do
we need the first garble circuit the
root garble circuit we need if you're
doing t reads we need t of them for the
children we need t by two and and so on
right
so now that we have answered the q first
question and how many do we need under
this uh uh assumption that we're going
to focus on for the rest of the talk how
do we connect them it's sort of a
somewhat tricky problem
so let's see if i went left for example
right so if i was going this is the root
node and i i go left
then this second
garble circuit in the root needs to
replace the first die
but it needs to have hard coded in it
the input labels of
the the
the second left child and the first
right child
right
and well i could have also gone right if
i went right then i need to remember the
the first left child and the second
right child
so in effect i need the second
a
garbled circular needs to remember both
the the input labels of the
first and the second left and the first
and the second right child and this
number will keep growing as you go
further okay
so the number of keys that need to be
hard-coded
in each circuit needs to keep growing
uh
but hopefully not all because
we have assumed there is uniform memory
access hopefully at some point we can
stop hard coding keys and if you had a
large enough window it might suffice
actually it is not true because even if
you had t reads with the with the
noticeable probability you'll have a
discrepancy of square root t and you
need to remember uh square root keys
okay
we have a sort of a acute fix around it
and the idea in our case is we're going
to have a moving window just as i sort
of motivated yes
you know the teeth layer always just
you know discard the the top one and
always just do that that layer if you
did that you will need a t-garble
circuits for the children t for the
sub-children and so on
the growth is t times m then not it's
not reducing
okay
yes uh okay i should be done um so i
i'll have a moving window so i'll
uh
for example in this which is the fourth
root garble circuit i have a window of
keys for the left children and window
keys for the right children and the next
one will have a a window that moves a
little ahead
uh
this in order to make this idea work
what we need to do is ins
have a the number of garble circuit
which is slightly larger than the uh the
expected amount so we have one plus
epsilon times the garble circuits that
are sort of needed in expectation and
this gives us two guarantees one if i'm
lagging behind so if i am you know
i'm behind the window that my parent
expects me to be in then i can
artificially consume garbled circuits
and push myself in the window
and the other thing is if i am already
ahead i would by chernobyl not be go
beyond this barrier of one plus epsilon
we need this epsilon to be little of one
for the
scheme to remain efficient but but it
sort of works out
okay so now that i've described the
solution which sort of deals with m
reads now i need to deal with the case
where i have more unbounded reads right
back to abby's question so the idea for
that is you know i have to do that but
in sort of an oblivious way i don't know
what reads actually happened i just know
that they're sort of somewhat uniform
given that i want to be able to
replenish my memory uh
and the idea for that
is
i'll have a sort of a continuous
replenishing mechanism as i use the
memory a little bit i'll add a little
more but since there is a big enough
buffer between the consumption and the
addition it doesn't matter which places
you consumed does that make sense
so i have these uh these cues for the
root and so on
i'll keep adding garble circuits to each
of these queues
and at each step i'll add the number of
garble circuits that i'll send with each
garbled circuit will be proportional to
the number of reads that specific
garbled circuit mix
yes yes and then there is a queue in the
middle which ensures that uh
the obliviousness is preserved
any questions
okay
so the security actually has a couple of
other issues i won't talk about how we
solve them but just to give you a flavor
of the kind of techniques that go in
the first is the the construction that i
just described has a circularity issue
sort of somewhat similar to the original
lewistrovsky solution the reason being
that i have one garbled circuit and the
input labels of this garble circuit are
hardware at multiple places
and and to be able to invoke the
security of an individual one i need to
get rid of all of them before i can do
that
so this is some issue that we we do
resolve and need some care but sort of
an interesting issue that it comes up
the second is that
in our setting the garble circuits are
sort of not executed in a linear way so
one garble circuit has its input labels
that come from different sources and are
provided at different times so that sort
of leads to other security complications
okay
okay so let me conclude
to make sure hugo doesn't get too upset
a little okay so uh a cryptography for
we have been doing cryptography for for
circuits for a long long time and uh
we've done fairly well but we should now
move on to ram programs and and really i
think there is a great scope for for
getting a lot of efficiency here and
this is sort of the right direction to
pursue
within ram computation
uh typical solutions for example what
tal talked about uh it typically
required large round complexity in
particular the round complexity needs to
grow linearly in the running time of the
the program
and and uh the reason for not having uh
lower round complexity has been this
non-black box use of cryptography and
this sort of has been a barrier that
whenever we tried to make things
non-interactive we we had to sort of
inherently use non-black box techniques
and this is sort of the barrier that we
overcome in uh this result
uh i expect the many consequences of the
techniques that we have developed for
example uh in symmetric searchable
encryption we have solutions which are
uh fairly efficient they're very
non-interactive but they do not get the
best security uh the techniques that we
have are asymptotically good but they're
not
practical in any sense
but i do believe that we could extend
them and get solutions which are
which cross that barrier of doing better
security and still remaining in the
regime of
a
practical or theoretically practical
efficiency
okay so thanks
actually i really like to finish this
workshop with that last sentence
saying that
we we can unify the these two parts of
this uh
shot the more
theoretical one and the more one the one
trying to go more for practice and bring
them together i definitely believe so
one question
very good yeah
when you refresh the memory it seems
like the garbage circuit has to make the
carbon circuit to refresh the memory so
i don't see how you got around the
we don't
the garble circuit doesn't generate that
we just give
it's a q right and there has to be a
garble circuit which is missing i'll
just give you that garble circuit
right so the first time for for every
read i'll give you
uh the i so for if i'm reading
replenishing the ith time i'll give you
the ayat if the number of garble circuit
that needed from the root to the ith
leaf which is sort of proportional to
just logarithmic factors right
gerbil circuits never generate other
carbon circuits they will certainly just
have labels inside of them in their
belly for the global circuit there's a
lot of labeling yes
labels being passed and labels for
labels of labels
okay